Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and during my
episode 3 review I asked you all to submit
questions about the big WTF change to Jaime’s
character and all the other big moments.
So I picked 10 of them to answer in this video
with one bonus questions.
We’ve also got to give a high five to this
week’s giveaway winner Theresa Harris
You win a $20 amazon gift card, I’ll be
‘DMing you on your channel for details.
Next round starts when I post my episode 4
video.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m just doing a weekly giveaway to say
thanks to all you guys for being so awesome.
So we have a lot to talk about, since so many
people were so upset about what happened with
Jaime’s character I wanted to address that
first.
So just because this was a pretty big deal
everybody please be nice to each other no
matter what your opinion is on the matter.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet but here we go.
Question 1 - Bloody Desires asks Do you think
the way Jaime was durning that scene was out
of character considering his development so
far?
Considering he saved Brienne from getting
raped before they cut his hand off.
Yes definitely, George RR Martin even wrote
something on his blog about it.
He basically said that because the show brought
Jaime back to King’s Landing earlier, the
whole dynamic between him and Cersei changed.
In the book version of that scene, Cersei
is seeing Jaime for the first time and she
wants him as badly as he wants her.
Her only hesitancy is that they’ll be caught.
But on the show because Jaime has been back
for weeks and they’ve been fighting the
whole context is changed.
Martin also kind of distanced himself also
by saying that he never talked to D and D
about the scene.
I think it’s unfortunate because Jaime’s
character is supposed to be on something of
a redemptive arc.
He’s trying to be more like Brienne.
And this scene destroyed that.
They have follow up scenes next week which
will spell out a little more where the show
is taking Jaime this season.
I think the other question we need to ponder
in the comments below is whether or not they
just made mistakes in the writing and filming
on the scene.
Did they intend for it to be the way we saw
it or did the actors and the director just
go to far while they were filming it?
Question 2 - Valentino asks When do you think
Stannis will march on the wall?
Not before Davos follows up on that letter
to the Iron Bank of Braavos.
Remember that scene where the boat passes
underneath it in the trailer?
I think that was Daavos visiting the bank.
The bank has really started to become a plot
point this season.
Remember how the crown is in debt to them
big time, Lady Olenna was talking to Tywin
about it and he kind of shrugged it off.
It sounds like Daavos is going to use that
to get money from the Iron Bank.
But I’m really interested to see if they
become a much bigger part of the story in
the future.
Promises to the bank have to be kept.
Otherwise they’ll turn around and fund your
enemies.
Question 3 - Steve Sunny asks why is Dorne
an Independent Kingdom
So I actually got a bunch of questions about
Dorne and why they have a Prince but not a
King and how they were able to resist Aegon
Targaryen’s Conquest of Westeros.
So this is meant to collectively sum up all
the answers.
The reason Dorne has a prince but not a King
is that when Aegon Targaryen conquered Westeros
Dorne used much smarter military tactics and
because of the desert and the mountains they
were able to drive the Targaryen’s out.
Their covert tactics made it so that the Targaryen’s
couldn’t use their dragons like they did
on all the other armies.
Then by the time Baelor the Blessed became
king, remember Twyin mentioned him in his
speech to Tommen, he used a bunch of marriage
pacts to bring Dorne into the kingdom.
But as part of that arrangement, each new
ruler of Dorne got to keep the title Prince.
So there’s only one King of Westeros, but
Dorne still has a prince, whereas all the
other noble houses are just Lords and Ladies.
Right now Myrcella is betrothed to one of
the really young Martell princes.
Question 4 - Sairys Torres asks Who’s the
King now?
And is Margeary the Queen?
Tommen is the king if that wasn’t clear
in the episode.
But until he’s old enough to make political
and policy decisions, Tywin will effectively
be the real ruler.
Tommen will just be a figurehead until then.
In the books they make him sound much much
younger.
The actor on the show almost looks like a
teenager.
He was seven in season 1, so now he’s supposed
to be like 10 or 11 I think.
So they aged him up.
In the book all they really let him do is
stamp documents as if it’s a game.
Like you would finger paint.
Except he’s finger painting the royal seal
on important documents.
Just another example of a big change the show
has made whether you agree with it or not.
Question 5 - Danny Stones asks do you think
Littlefinger is going to train Sansa to play
the Game of Thrones?
I don’t think she’s going to follow the
same path as Arya, she’s not going to turn
into a super spy or anything.
I hope that she gets wiser and more cunning.
Until now the most common adjective used to
describe her has been sweet as in Sweet Sansa.
She is kind of like a leaf being blown around
by all these big forces and up to now, she’s
kind of just done and believed whatever anyone
has told her.
So hopefully this season we’ll see her do
something really cool.
If you’re reading the books, she’s going
to be a POV character in Winds of Winter.
So I’m hoping for some badass Sansa moments.
But don’t hold your breathe.
Question 6 - Peter Cho asks Why are the cannibals
traveling with Ygritte's group?
The Thenns are just part of the raiding party
that’s trying to open that gate at Castle
Black.
It can only be opened from the other side
of the wall.
So Mance Rayder can’t bring his army through
until it’s opened.
And the wildlings can’t open it until they
eat a lot of crow.
In the books the Thenns weren’t cannibals,
but another tribe of wildlings were.
There are a ton of them, so the show had to
cut a bunch of them out of the story.
I think for one of my bonus videos in the
future I’ll do a wildling video and talk
about each of the tribes.
They’re really interesting, but there’s
so many of them you kind of have to do a separate
video for it.
Question 7 - Casey asks Do you think Tywin
is taking Tommen under his wing because he
doesn’t want another Joffrey situation?
I definitely think he’s aware Tommen is
open to suggestion.
Remember how he went straight to marriage
and heirs.
He’s all about the Lannister bloodline and
duty to family.
Mostly that the line continues.
Instead of the birds and the bees, with him
it’s more like the Business and the bees.
I don’t think he’s necessarily evil, he’s
more like a grumpy Vulcan.
He has this vision for his family and the
kingdom and now, he thinks he’s in a place
where people won’t cause him so many problems.
The big issue with Joffrey was that he made
decisions without consulting Tywin or he just
flat out did the opposite.
The first really good example was beheading
Ned Stark.
Tywin wouldn’t have done that, it’s primarily
what started the War of the Five Kings.
Question 8 - Chad Morton (no avatar) asks
Why does Alliser Thorne hate Jon Snow?
When Jon first came to the watch Alliser who
was the master at arms just mocked him by
calling him Lord Snow, just making fun of
the fact he was a highborn Bastard who ended
up at the Night’s Watch.
Which is kind of like the ultimate Chain Gang
of Westeros.
Eventually Jon made fun of him back and that’s
when Alliser started to outright hate him.
Bullies don’t like to be bullied themselves.
It’s not a very good reason to hate someone.
But the book version of the character is a
very petty person.
Question 9 - Gaz2D2 (no avatar) asks Do you
think the Game of Thrones TV show will feature
any flashbacks?﻿
I think there will be some flashbacks when
Bran finally meets the Three-Eyed Raven.
He’ll tell Bran his story, how he came to
be where his is.
So they’ll have to show something from his
past.
It just seems too cool not to, especially
with that dream sequence they did when Bran
warged with the tree.
That bonus video I’m doing on Sunday is
for the Bloodraven, that was one of his names
before he became the Three-Eyed Raven.
So it will explain his history in Westeros
in much greater detail.
It’s pretty cool.
I won’t talk about anything that’s going
to happen in the future on the show though.
Question 10 - Martin asks Do you feel that
the Hound has become more docile since teaming
up with Arya?
I think Arya is rubbing off on him and every
once and a while he acknowledges it, then
does everything he can to shake it off.
Like when they were taken in by the farmer.
He played along and you could see he thought
about staying and helping them.
But then by morning his own sense of self-loathing
rises up and he shakes of all the niceness
and robs the hell out of them.
It’s almost like he hates himself so much
that anytime anyone shows him kindness he
doesn’t believe it or he treats it with
disgust.
I really think Arya is getting tired of him.
They have a kind of temporary truce going
right now.
Arya knows he can help her get away and the
Hound knows she’s still worth money to someone.
And one last Bonus Question - side effect
(no avatar) asks How big role will Mark Gatiss
have?﻿
I don’t think it will be Mycroft big if
that’s what you’re wondering.
He’s playing someone who works for the Iron
Bank.
I haven’t seen him on the show yet.
So I think when we see Braavos we’ll see
him.
Daavos is going to have to borrow a lot of
money to get Stannis an Army.
There was a shout out for the Gold Company,
so he might try to use the money to hire them
as a mercenary army.
Which reminds me, even if that doesn’t end
up happening, I’ll do a bonus video for
some of the mercenary companies eventually.
One for the Second Sons and one for the Gold
Company.
They both have a really cool history.
So thank you so much for submitting questions,
I’m sure the Jaime Cersei debate will go
on forever, but like I said my next bonus
video will be the Bloodraven on Sunday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
And leave me suggestions for other bonus videos
to do in the comments.
Right now click here for my Bonus Video on
the history of Meereen and Slaver’s Bay
and click here for my review of the episode.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!